THREE ON A BERMAN EQUALITY IS
HEREBY CALL TO ORDER. WE HAVE A
ONE ITEM BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
THIS IS AT AB TWELVE NINETY
NINE BY CELL NUMBER SALAS. AND
ALASKAN TO APPROACH THE DYSON.
DO YOU WANT TO GO PRESENT YOUR.
OUR PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR WAS OUR
TITLES HERE AS WELL OUR OUR
COLLEAGUE. AND YOU'RE WELCOME
TO. JOIN US AS WELL. I THINK IT
WAS SHARE MEMBERS A- WE
PRESENTS ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE
NINETY NINE. THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT TWELVE
MADE IT TO THE COMMITTEE TODAY
THIS BILL WILL FIX SOME OF THE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES. OF
PREVIOUS LEGISLATION NAMELY AB
SIXTEEN FORTY SEVEN WHICH WAS
PASSED IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN OF
THIS LEGISLATION PLACE AN EQUAL
BURDEN ON. SMALL FAMILY OWNED
REFINERIES BY REQUIRING THEM TO
COMPLY WITH THE SAME RULES AS
MULTINATIONAL REFINERIES. THAT
AB SIXTEEN FORTY SEVEN ARRAY
ORIGINALLY SET UP TO TARGET.
WITHOUT I'LL GO AHEAD AND ALLOW
FOR ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY. I AM
THANK YOU TERRY THANK YOU
MEMBERS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE.
MY NAME IS JENNIFER HALEY I'M
THE PRESIDENT OF CURRENT OIL
REFINING COMPANY. WE ARE A
SMALL FAMILY OWNED FACILITY
OPERATING IN BAKERSFIELD
CALIFORNIA WHERE TWENTY SIX
THOUSAND BARRELS PER DAY
CAPACITY. AND TO PUT THAT IN
PERSPECTIVE SOME OF THE LARGER
REFINERS IN THE STATE ARE TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
BARRELS CAPACITY SO TEN TIMES
OUR SIZE. I'M WE ARE HERE
BECAUSE WE GOT CAUGHT UP IN
LEGISLATION THAT WAS NEVER
INTENDED TO APPLY TO US. WE
WERE ASSURED BY THE BILL'S
AUTHOR AT THAT KERN WAS NOT THE
INTENDED TARGET OF THE
LEGISLATION. AND ACTUALLY IN
THE INTERIM THE SOUTH COAST AIR
QUALITY POLLUTION CONTROL
DISTRICT HAS ACTUALLY. INVENTED
REFINERIES THAT ARE BELOW FORTY
THOUSAND BARRELS PER DAY. SO
THIS IS REALLY A MATTER OF
EQUITY WHERE IF WE WERE IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY WE WOULD BE
EXEMPTED BUT WE ARE NOT
EXEMPTED UNDER THE CURRENT.
WE'LL WORK CLOSELY WITH OUR
LOCAL AIR POLLUTION DISTRICT
AND THEY HAVE BEEN VERY HELPFUL
AND SUPPORTIVE AND REASONABLE.
BUT THEY NEED CLARIFICATION
THAT THAT WE SHOULD BE EXEMPTED
UNDER THIS LEGISLATION. AND SO
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IS
WERE FINALLY LOCATED IN THE
SOUTHERN SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY. WE
ARE ALREADY SUBJECT TO SOME OF
THE STRICTEST MONITORING
REQUIREMENTS IN THE STATE. WE
HAVE DAILY WEEKLY AND MONTHLY
MONITORING ACTIVITIES. THE
POLLUTANTS THAT ARE MONITORED
INCLUDE CARBON DIOXIDE VOLATILE
ORGANIC COMPOUNDS SOCKS. WE
ACTUALLY HAVE CONTINUOUS
MONITORING DEVICES ON OUR FUEL
GAS SYSTEM. AND ALSO ON OUR
FLARE AND THAT GOES DIRECTLY
LIVE TO THE AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL DISTRICT. I AM NOT HERE
TO SAY THAT I AM AGAINST
MONITORING FAR FROM IT. KERN
HAS BEEN AN EXAMPLE OF A
REFINERY THAT HAS EMBRACED THE
STATE'S CLIMATE CHANGE GOALS.
AND ALSO THE EMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS. BUT THIS TYPE OF
MONITORING WOULD NOT MAKE SENSE
FOR A FACILITY OF OUR SIZE. FOR
US TO SPEND BETWEEN ONE AND A
HALF AND THREE MILLION DOLLARS
BUT THIS MONITORING IN PLACE
THAT WAS NEVER SUPPOSED TO
APPLY TO US TO BEGIN WITH. WHAT
THAT IS DOING IS DIVERTING ARE
SCARCE RESOURCES AWAY FROM
PROJECTS ARE ACTUALLY GOING TO
HELP OUR COMMUNITY. ACTUALLY
HELP OUR FACILITY EXPAND OUR
RENEWABLE FUELS REDUCE OUR
EMISSIONS. SOME OF THE PROJECTS
THAT WE'RE CONSIDERING RIGHT
NOW INCLUDES EMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS AND PUTTING IN NEW
BURNER TECHNOLOGY THAT WOULD
REDUCE OUR PETER SHINS AFTER.
THAT WERE ACTUALLY LOOKING AT
TWO MEGAWATT SOLAR FACILITY.
I'M I'M JUST TRYING TO GIVE
SOME EXAMPLES WE ARE TRYING TO
BE A GOOD CORPORATE CITIZEN AND
WE'RE TRYING TO BE A GOOD
MEMBER OF THE COMMUNITY. AND
SPENDING MONEY ON THIS AIR
MONITORING THAT'S NOT INTENDED
FOR US PARTICULARLY EMISSIONS
PROFILE OF OUR SIZE. JUST
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE. OKAY THANK
YOU OTHER FOLKS. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN RECESS FOR THE
US ON BEHALF OF THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL HERE GO ON WE
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS
LEGISLATION WE HAVE BEEN
SUPPORTIVE OF ALL OF THE
STATE'S CLIMATE. CHANGE
POLICIES THEY HAVE ALSO
PROVIDED NOT ONLY THE
OPPORTUNITIES TO WORK ON SUCH
REFINERIES BUT ALSO TO CREATE
OPPORTUNITIES BUILDING
RENEWABLE SOLAR PLANTS AND ALSO
WHEN PLANTS IN AND AROUND THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AREA NEAR WITH
THIS ACTUAL REFINERY IS
LOCATED. WE HAVE MEMBERS FROM
IBEW LOCAL FOUR TWENTY EIGHT WE
HAVE PLUMBERS AND PIPEFITTERS
FROM LOCAL FOR SIXTY AND
CARPENTERS THAT ROUTINELY
WORKING IN AROUND THESE
FACILITIES PERFORMING THE TYPES
OF PROJECTS THAT WERE
MENTIONED. ACTUALLY MODERNIZE
THE FACILITY. BUT NOT ACHIEVING
THESE PROJECTS WHAT HAPPENS IS
THAT A LOT OF THE EMISSIONS
WILL CONTINUE TO MAKE THE AREAS
POLLUTION WORSE. AND PERHAPS
TAKE AWAY THE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
SOME OF OUR MEMBERS ACTUALLY
WORK LOCALLY. HAVING THEN TO
TRAVEL TO DIFFERENT AREAS
BECAUSE CONSTRUCTION IS CIVIL
GLANCE ALSO REGIONAL AND THAT
WHILE ALSO ADD MORE POLLUTION
TO THE AREA. THE AREA DOES NOT
HAVE THAT MUCH ECONOMIC
DIVERSITY THERE'S NOT THAT MANY
JOBS IN THERE IN FACT IT'S
DOUBLE THE ACTUAL UNEMPLOYMENT
RATE IN THIS AREA AND KERN
COUNTY. COMPARED TO THE REST
THE STATE THERE AT THREE POINT
EIGHT WHILE THE STATE THAT I
MEAN I'M SORRY THREE POINT IS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
UNEMPLOYMENT. 8% IS A RATE IN
KERN COUNTY ALONE. AND SO THESE
ARE IMPORTANT JOBS THE JOBS ARE
IN AND AROUND THESE AREAS DON'T
PAY AS WELL. AS SOME OF OUR
MEMBERS ARE ACTUALLY MAKING
THESE ARE ITSELF. AND WE'RE
ASKING FOR IS SOME TIME AND
SOME FLEXIBILITY FOR THE SMALL
REFINERIES TO ACTUALLY PERFORM.
A DIFFERENT TYPE OF MONITORING
THAT'S NOT WITH LIKE WITH THE
LARGE FACILITIES ARE ARE HAVING
TO DO AND WE FULLY SUPPORT
LARGE FACILITIES BECAUSE WE
HAVE BEEN SUPPORTER OF THE OF
BILLS BACK IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
TO ADD THOSE HIGHER STANDARDS
AND REGULATIONS TO THOSE
FACILITIES BUT FOR THESE SMALL
ONES I THINK THEY DESERVE A
SECOND LOOKING FOR THE REASONS.
ALREADY STATED WE HUMBLY ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
UNDER SOAK GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS YOU
KNOW FIRST AND FOREMOST I WANT
TO. JUST MAKE IT CLEAR THE AIR
QUALITY IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
TO US AND THE CENTRAL VALLEY
AND AS IS CLEAN WATER AND- BUT
YOU KNOW THE TOP THERE'S ALSO
DO YOUR JOBS IS ALSO IMPORTANT
TO US GIVEN THAT WE HAVE A
HIGHER DOUBLE DIGIT.
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE IN THE VALLEY
WE'RE TRYING TO MAKE IT BETTER
TO PROVIDE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
PEOPLE. THIS BILL DOES IT DOES
NOT. REDUCE THE CURRENT LEVELS
OF MONITORING IMPOSED BY THE
STATE AND THE LOCAL AIRPORT. IT
SIMPLY STATES THAT DUE TO A
FACILITY SIZE IN AN EIGHT LEVEL
OF A PRODUCTION IT SHOULD NOT
BE CONSIDERED IN THE SAME WAY
AS A FACILITY THAT PRODUCE
ECONOMICALLY MORE PRODUCT
ADMISSIONS. AT THIS BILL WILL
OF DELIVERY EIGHTY ONE SIZE
FITS ALL APPROACH. THAT WAS
APPLIED TO THE STATE AND TWENTY
SEVENTEEN. ARE THROUGH A. B.
SIXTEEN FORTY SEVEN AND YOU
KNOW FOR THE REASONS THAT WERE
STATED TO BAD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR NIVEAU. THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR. OKAY LOOKS YOU WANT TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. I'M OTHERS
YOU FOLKS WANT TO RAISE
OPPOSITION OR CONCERNS ABOUT
THE BILL. KAMALA. THAT ONE WORD.
GOOD AFTERNOON KEREN MEMBERS MY
NAME IS KATIE VIOLENCE WELL AND
I'M THE POLICY AND POLITICAL
DIRECTOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ALLIANCE
WE ARE STATEWIDE COALITION OF
GRASSROOTS GROUPS SEEKING TO
ACHIEVE ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
AND WE ARE HERE TODAY WITH A
MORE THAN TWENTY GRASSROOTS
ORGANIZATIONS AND ADVOCACY
GROUPS IN OPPOSITION TO THE
SPELL. WHEN OPERATING WITH AN
REGULATED LIMITS REFINERIES
ALREADY POSE SIGNIFICANT HEALTH
RISKS TO THE COMMUNITIES AS FAR
AS A MILE AWAY. THE REFINERY IN
QUESTION AND KERN COUNTY IS
LITERALLY ACROSS THE STREET
FROM A COMMUNITY OF OVER NINE
HUNDRED PEOPLE WHO ARE
PREDOMINANTLY LATINO AND ONE
THIRD CHILDREN. THE MONITORS
ARE THERE TO ENSURE THAT RULES
ARE FOLLOWED AND THAT
COMMUNITIES ARE PROTECTED AND
TO SAY THAT THOSE FAMILIES
DON'T DESERVE THE SAME
PROTECTION AS URBAN COMMUNITIES
AS OFFENSIVE ABOUT POLICY.
SPEAKING ABOUT POLICY WE
BELIEVE THAT THE SOUTH COAST
EXEMPTION OF SMALL PRODUCERS
WAS NOT AN APPROPRIATE
INTERPRETATION OF THE MERCY
CHEAP BELL. TO MAKE AN
ADDITIONAL POLICY STATEMENT
BASS ON BASED ON NOT BAD POLICY
DECISION IT'S JUST ONE ABOUT
POLICY INFORMING ANOTHER. ON A
QUICK PERSONAL NOTE. I WAS BORN
AND RAISED IN KERN COUNTY MY
FAMILY STILL LIVES THERE I
TAKING HEALERS EVERY DAY AS A
RESULT OF GROWING UP IN SOME OF
THE WORST AIR QUALITY IN THE
COUNTRY. THIS BILL FLIES IN THE
FACE OF SIGNIFICANT HEALTH
EVIDENCE OF THE IMPACT OF OIL
ON THE COMMUNITIES IN THIS
COUNTRY. AND THIS COUNTY. AND
DECADES OF ADVOCACY THAT
NEIGHBORS LIKE MINE HAVE BEEN
DOING AGAINST OIL IN THIS
REGION. WE THINK THAT THE MONEY
THAT IS INVESTED TO PROTECT
COMMUNITIES PALES IN COMPARISON
TO THE MONEY THAT THEY SPEND
DEALING WITH THE IMPACTS OF
THESE FACILITIES AND WE BELIEVE
THAT WE ARE ENTITLED TO GOOD
JOBS AND CLEAN AIR. WE WANT TO
WORK WITH YOU ON NOT SOLUTION
NOT ON THIS ONE AND WE STRONGLY
URGE YOU TO OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. HI YES
SIR. GOOD AFTERNOON WILL BEAR
WITH THE AMERICAN LUNG
ASSOCIATION. WE ARE STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO THIS EFFORT TO
WEAKEN OR QUALITY MONITORING.
IN KERN COUNTY AT THE REFINERY.
KERN COUNTY IS RANKED NUMBER
ONE MOST POLLUTED COUNTY IN THE
UNITED STATES BY THE AMERICAN
LUNG ASSOCIATIONS TWENTY
NINETEEN STATED THE ERROR
REPORT ON PARTICLE POLLUTION.
AND NUMBER FIVE FOR OZONE
POLLUTION. THAT'S ACROSS THE
UNITED STATES NUMBER ONE NUMBER
FIVE FOR MOST POLLUTED AIR. WE
KNOW THE PEOPLE LIVING THERE
MAJOR SOURCES OF POLLUTION.
FACE GREATER RISKS DUE TO THAT
LOCAL OUR PROXIMITY. GREATER
RISK OF ASTHMA ATTACKS. GREATER
CANCER RISKS. GREATER IMPACT A
HEART HEALTH AND PREMATURE
DEATH. AIR QUALITY MONITORING
ALLOWS US TO US IN OUR AIR
DISTRICTS AND LOCAL COMMUNITIES
TO UNDERSTAND THE LEVEL OF
RISK. THAT THEY FACE FROM LOCAL
POLLUTION SOURCES. THEY HELP US
TO UNDERSTAND THOSE LOOK A RISK
TO CREATE COMMITTEE PROTECTIVE
PLANS. AND IMPLEMENT REDUCTIONS
IN TOXIC AIR CONTAMINANTS THAT
THREATEN PUBLIC HEALTH. THIS
BILL MEANS LESS INFORMATION FOR
PEOPLE LIVING NEAR. OIL
REFINERY IN KERN COUNTY AGAIN
THE MOST POLLUTED COUNTY IN THE
UNITED STATES. WE OPPOSE THIS
BILL WE BELIEVE IT IS A BAD
POLICY WE BELIEVE THAT I GOT
AMEND PROCESS FOR SOMETHING OF
THIS IMPORTANCE. IS BETTER
PROCESS AND THE PRESIDENT IS
ALSO BAD WE BELIEVE THIS IS BAD
FOR PUBLIC HEALTH. ENERGY TO
OPPOSE. THE FOLKS WHO WANT TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. HELLO
ERICA MARTINEZ WITH EARTH
JUSTICE UP WE ARE A NONPROFIT
LAW FIRM WE DO A LOT OF WORK AT
SOUTH COAST AND WE WERE REALLY
SURPRISED TO SEE THAT SOUTH
COAST AND IS BEING USED AS AN
EXAMPLE WITH THEIR REGULATIONS
WHICH WE BELIEVE ARE UNLAWFUL
AND INCONSISTENT WITH THE
LEGISLATION THAT YOU PASSED IN
APPROVED. WE ALSO BELIEVE IN
JOBS THE ENVIRONMENT AND PUBLIC
HEALTH AND THIS BILL DOES NOT
STRIKE THE RIGHT BALANCE TODAY
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING
OTHER TYPES OF CONVERSATION SO
THAT WE CAN ADDRESS. ALL THOSE
THREE THINGS TOGETHER THANK YOU.
I DELIVERED WITH LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL FOR JUSTICE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY. WE WORK
DIRECTLY WITH SOME OF THE
COMMUNITIES THAT WOULD BE
NEGATIVELY IMPACTED BY THIS
BILL AND STRONGLY STRONGLY
OPPOSE IT FOR THE REASONS
STATED BY MY COLLEAGUES. FROM
IN THE OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
BILL MCGOVERN WITH COALITION
FOR CLEAN AIR WE'RE OPPOSED TO
ASK YOU NOT TO PUT A LOOPHOLE.
IN A REFINERY MONITORING LAW.
AND NOT TO SACRIFICE THE HEALTH
OF THE RESIDENTS TO THE
REFINERY THANK YOU. AMY GO ON
BEHALF OF THE CENTRAL VALLEY
AIR QUALITY COALITION IN
OPPOSITION. ONE OF THE MADE ON
A WITHOUT ALONG CALIFORNIANS
FROM THE OPPOSITION. TURNOVERS
NIKITA CRIED WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL
STRONGLY OPPOSED. FOUR COMMA
ZERO CLUB CALIFORNIA WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
AARON RODRIGUEZ FOR THE UNION
OF CONCERNED SCIENTISTS AND
STRONG OPPOSITION. MELISSA
ROMERO WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF CONSERVATION VOTERS
IN STRONG OPPOSITION AND I WAS
ALSO ASKED TO PASS ALONG THE
OPPOSITION OF THE ENVIRONMENTAL
DEFENSE FUND THANK YOU. BERMAN
CALIFORNIA CHEN JACOBSON POST.
ANOTHER ASK IS HERE REGISTRY IN
OPPOSITION FOR BOTH CENTER
REYES HARDING OF OUR MEN WHO
ALSO WORKS IN KERN COUNTY AND
ALSO REGISTRY OPPOSITION FOR
THE COMMITTEES FOR BETTER
ENVIRONMENT THAT ALSO
REPRESENTS LA COMMUNITIES AND
THE BAY AREA. RENDON TOOK ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA AIR
POLLUTION CONTROL OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION. WE'RE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE POTENTIAL
NEGATIVE HEALTH IMPACTS THE A
BAD PRECEDENT THE BILL SETS
I'VE ALSO HEARD THAT SOUTH
COASTAL MENTIONED. BY VARIOUS
PEOPLE I DID WANT TO POINT OUT
THE DISTINCTION BETWEEN. THIS
PROPOSAL AND THAT IS THAT THAT
WAS. SOMETHING THAT WAS ADOPTED
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL AND WENT
THROUGH A LOCAL PROCESS RATHER
THAN AN EXEMPTION APPEAR AT THE
STATE LEVEL SO I JUST WANTED.
IN THAT THANK YOU. OKAY HOW THE
ITEMS BEFORE THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS I CENTER HELL. THANK
YOU SEE HERE IN THIS IS A TOUGH
ONE OF. BECAUSE CERTAINLY YOU
KNOW AS YOU KNOW THE CHAIR OF
THE BAY AREA DISTRIBUTOR I'M
SITTING ON CARP FOR A WHILE AND
KNOWING THAT THE VALLEY IN KERN
COUNTY IS THE MOST POLLUTED
AREA OF THE STATE. THE HEALTH
RISK IS SUBSTANTIAL OF. THAT
THERE WAS A GOOD. COMMENT
RAISED ABOUT THE AMOUNT. I
GUESS THE MONITORING THAT IS
NOW GOING ON. THE REGULAR
MONITORING BY THE AIR DISTRICT
WHAT IS THAT AND HOW OFTEN AND
WITH WITH ACTUALLY. ARE DOING
IN THAT MARKET THEY COME OUT ON
A REGULAR BASIS. SO THE CURRENT
MONITORING AND I'M FRANKLY NOT
GONNA BE ABLE TO SUMMARIZE ALL
THAT WE DO. BUT LIKE I SAID WE
HAVE DAILY WEEKLY AND MONTHLY
MONITORING ACTIVITIES WE
CURRENTLY MONITOR FOR. CARBON
DIOXIDE VOLATILE ORGANIC
COMPOUNDS SOCKS LIKE I SAID
THAT WE HAVE THE CONTINUOUS
MONITORING ON OR FEEL GAS
SYSTEM IN OUR FLARE. I CAN ALSO
PULL AND WE HAVE OUR GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS MANAGER WHO ALSO WAS
OUR ENVIRONMENTAL MANAGER WHO
WOULD BE ABLE TO ADD. SOME
ADDITIONAL DETAIL AT. THE
DESIRED YOU KNOW ONE YEAR.
LATER. HEY THANK YOU MELINDA
HEX. TO FURTHER WHAT JENNIFER
WAS SAYING ABOUT OUR MONITORING
REQUIREMENTSI'M SHE GAVE ME
THE VARIOUS FREQUENCIES AND
THAT COVERS A MULTITUDE OF OUR
EQUIPMENT OVER TWO DOZEN PIECES
OF EQUIPMENT THAT WE HAVE THAT
IS COVERED BY THAT. AND I THINK
THE FURTHER ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION ABOUT WHAT THE ERROR
DISTRICT DOES AND THEY ARE OUT
ON A ROUTINE BASIS THEY HAVE
STRICT REQUIREMENTS THAT
THEY'RE HELD TO. BY EPA SO THEY
ARE IN OUR FACILITY VERY
REGULARLY. AND THEY THEMSELVES
MONITOR. ALL THE SAME PIECES OF
EQUIPMENT THAT WE DO THROUGH
THE COURSE OF THEIR ANNUAL
INSPECTION AND WHEN I SAY
ANNUAL IT'S NOT ONCE A YEAR
THAT THEY COME OUT WE SEE THEM.
MINIMAL AT A MINIMUM ONCE A
MONTH SOMETIMES QUITE MORE
OFTEN THAN THAT WE MAY HAVE
THEM IN THE FACILITY TWO OR
THREE DAYS A WEEK AT CERTAIN
TIMES. IN THE. THERE WAS A
MENTION I THINK IN IN A SYSTEM
OF DISCUSSING THE- HE- A
REQUEST OR HAVE YOU APPLIED TO
THE AIR DISTRICT FOR THIS
EXEMPTION. WE HAVE BEEN WE HAVE
BEEN WORKING WITH THE AIR
DISTRICT ON THIS AND I THINK
WE'RE VERY HAPPY TO SAY THAT
THE DISTRICT. UNDERSTANDS AND
THEY'VE BEEN WORKING WITH US TO
THE DEGREE THAT THEY CAN IT IS
OUR UNDERSTANDING THAT THEY
DON'T FEEL THAT THE LEGISLATION
ALREADY IN PLACE IMPOSING THESE
REQUIREMENTS QUITE GIVES THEM
THE LATITUDE TO DO ANYTHING
FURTHER THAN WHAT THEY ARE
TODAY AND THAT THIS WOULD GIVE
THEM THAT ADDITIONAL
CONFIRMATION THAT THEY NEED.
THEY HEARD FROM THE OPPOSITION
THAT THEY FELT THAT THE IF THE
SOUTH COAST ACTUALLY. WENT
ABOVE AND BEYOND THE AUTHORITY
THAT THEY HAD BY BY OFFERING
THAT EXEMPTION THERE AS WELL SO
I MEAN IT'S TROUBLING THE. TO
SEE AND DO HERE IS I I'M JUST
LOOK AT THE NUMBERS WHICH
TWENTY THOUSAND BARRELS A DAY
TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND BARRELS A
DAY WHICH IS. QUITE LOW.
COMPARED TO SO MANY OF THE
REFINERY SO THIS DATA A
CHALLENGE IN AND I AM CONCERNED
ABOUT THE DISTRICT SO I WILL.
PROBABLY TODAVíA SUPPORTING
THIS BILL TO KEEP IT MOVING.
AND HAVE SOME FOR THE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT IT SO THANK
YOU. THANK SAID. I'M I KNOW THE
CENTER GROVE IS HERE AND I
THINK AS A COURTESY WE WANT TO
GIVE HER AN OPPORTUNITY TO.
RECENT COMMENTS. MONEY CAN
FIFTY. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
YOU KNOW IT'S NOT VERY OFTEN IN
MOST CASES IN THE STATE THAT WE
GET TO CROSS THE ISLAND WORK
TOGETHER ON ON OUR DISTRICTS
AND SO IT'S I'M NOT IT'S AN
HONOR FOR ME TO SIT HERE WITH
SENATOR HER TATO AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SALAS TO WORK HARD TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE JOBS THAT
ARE CREATED IN THE DISTRICT ARE
PROTECTED THIS OIL REFINERY IS
A VERY VERY SMALL REFINERY
COMPARED TO THE LEGISLATION
THAT WAS ENACTED THAT WAS TO
AFFECT REFINERIES REFINERIES.
AND WE ALL UNDERSTAND THE
ISSUES THAT WE HAVE WITH AIR
QUALITY OF BUT TO ALLOW THIS TO
FIND YOU TO CONTINUE IN AND
FOCUS ON ISSUES THAT ARE BETTER
FOR OUR COMMUNITY THAN THAN THE
SIMPLE FOR ARE NOT SIMPLE BUT
THE FENCE LINE MONITORING I
WOULD BE BENEFICIAL FOR KERN
COUNTY AND I'M PROUD TO STAND
WITH MY COLLEAGUES ON THE OTHER
SIDE OF THE AISLE TO WORK WITH.
HIM TO GET THIS ACCOMPLISHED
AND WE I WOULD REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR AYE THE. OKAY
THANK YOU CENTER HI SIR DOLLY.
OKAY SO. I HAVE A COUPLE
QUESTIONS FIRST OFF NUMBER ONE
THE. IN KERN AND FRESNO. THERE
WAS A STUDY DONE SOMETIME BACK
IF YOU TOOK EVERY. AND IN EVERY
POLLUTER OUT OF THEIR YOU'D
STILL HAVE POLLUTION THERE
BECAUSE OF THE BECAUSE QUITE
FRANKLY BECAUSE OF HOW THE
VALLEY LADIES AND SO I'VE IT'S
BEEN A FRUSTRATION OF MINE. I
ACTUALLY WORKED WITH THE SEVEN
MEMBER SALAS ON TRYING TO. KEEP
A BIOMASS PLANT OPERATING IN
HIS DISTRICT WHEN I WAS IN THE
STATE ASSEMBLY. AND WE HAD TO
WE HAD THIS YOU KNOW GROUP
COMMON TALK ABOUT. THAT
PARTICULAR MATTERS AND KERN AND
FRESNO WARY AND. AND YOU KNOW
WE WERE WE WERE TRYING TO KEEP
THAT THE FORCE FROM BURNING
DOWN WHICH CAUSES A LOT OF THIS
PARTICULAR MATTER SOME. MY
QUESTION ACTUALLY IS TO. TWO
BECAUSE OF THE WAY THE VALLEY
LAYS IN THE WAY THE- THE- THE
EIGHT MINUTES IS A- PET PEEVE
OF MINE I DON'T WANT TO. PICK A
FIGHT WITH MY FRIENDS FROM THE
COAST BUT- I HAVE TO STATE THE
FACTS AND THE FACTS ARE THAT
THEY GET A FREE RIDE OVER THERE
BECAUSE THE WIND BLOWS. ALL
THEIR POLLUTION INTO THE VALLEY
AND THESE PEOPLE HAVE TO BREED.
BECAUSE- THEY HAVE. THEIR
MANUFACTURING THERE IS. THEIR
QUALITIES BAD AND IS QUITE.
FRANKLY DUE TO. THE WAY THE
VALLEY LAYS IN THE WAY THE
WINDS BLOW. SO FOR ME IT'S A
QUESTION OF YOU KNOW. IF THE IF
THE NEIGHBORS THERE. IF YOU
REMOVE THIS PLAN COMPLETE EIGHT
THE PROBLEMS WOULD STILL BE THE
SAME. AND SO WE HAVE TO STRIKE
A BALANCE HERE SO WE ALLOW. THE
PM MONITORS AT THE COAST
BECAUSE. IT DOESN'T SINCE LAST
STAGNANT AIR AND THEY THEY GET
TO POLLUTE AND IT LANDS IN
THEIR BACKYARDS SO FOR ME
THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I
TRY TO WEIGH OUT ON THESE
DECISIONS OF. ARE WE ARE WE. IS
THAT WE NEED. IN THE VALLEY
BECAUSE OF WHERE THEY'RE AT AND
OTHER PEOPLE GET A FREE RIDE SO
THAT'S- ONE OF THIS IS I THINK
THAT NEEDS TO BE WAIT OUT IN
THIS. IS LEGISLATION THE OTHER
THING I WANT TO. WANT TO SHARE
WITH YOU IS THAT. YOU KNOW. IN
IN MAKING THOSE DETERMINATIONS.
OVER AND WHAT IS IT WHAT'S THE
DIFFERENCE A FEW THOUSAND HOW
MANY BARRELS THE DIFFERENCE IS
IT THAT YOU MEET UNDER THIS.
REQUIREMENT WAS IT TEN THOUSAND.
THE MATH HERE ANYWAY SO OUR
FACILITY IS TWENTY SIX THOUSAND
BARRELS PER DAY THE LARGER
REFINERS THAT THIS WAS INTENDED
FOR A TEN TIMES OUR SIZE OF TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND A DAY
ASH. THOSE ARE THE THOSE WILL
BE THE REASONS FOR ME TO BE
CONSIDERING THIS BILL. BECAUSE
I THINK THAT QUITE FRANKLY. THE
VALLEY HAS A REALLY BIG
CHALLENGES AND I THINK PART OF
MAJORITY YOUR PROBLEM IS NOT
FROM THE PEOPLE THAT ARE LOCAL
THEY'RE OF MAJORITY PROBLEMS
FROM POLLUTION COME IN FROM
SOMEWHERE ELSE. YEAH THAT
REALLY THE CASE. THAT'S RIGHT
IF YOU WANT YEAH THAT IS TRUE I
CAN LISTEN IN. OKAY STERN I
DON'T. IF I HAD TO GET THERE.
JUST TO JUST TO CLARIFY HOW THE
CLEAN AIR ACT WORKS IN
CALIFORNIA INTERBASE AND
TRANSPORT OF POLLUTANTS ARE
TAKEN INTO ACCOUNT FOR THE
CENTRAL VALLEY THE SAN JOAQUIN
AIR POLLUTION CONTROL DISTRICTS
PLAN SO IT'S SORT OF BACKED
OUT. THOSE BAY AREA NUMBERS AND
THE PRIMARY SOURCE OF POLLUTION
COURTING THE NUMBERS IS MOBILE
SOURCE THERE SO IN IN THE
VALLEY BUT THAT IS THAT I
WANTED TO TRY IT I KNOW THIS I
KNOW THIS IS A CRITICAL. ISSUE
FOR YOU ALL AND YOU'RE SAYING
YOU WANT TO DO THE RIGHT THING
AND WHICH I MEANT WHAT WOULD
YOU SAY A MILLION DOLLARS
MILLION AND A HALF TO. INSTALL
THE SYSTEM. YOU KNOW IT FRANKLY
IT DEPENDS WE DON'T KNOW
EXACTLY WHAT THE SYSTEMS WILL
LOOK LIKE RIGHT NOW WHICH
OBVIOUSLY GIVE US SOME
HEARTBURN BUT WE'RE LOOKING AT
A MILLION A HALF MAYBE EVEN UP
TO THREE MILLION DOLLARS SO. I
KNOW WE'VE TALKED IN THE PAST
ABOUT SOME YOUR EFFORTS ON LOW
CARBON FUEL PRODUCTION AND
OTHERS A PREMIUM IN THE
MARKETPLACE RIGHT NOW FOR
PRODUCTION THOSE LOWER LOW
CARBON FUELS. SO WANNA GET SENT
THROUGH A ABOUT THAT REVENUE
SOURCE AND THE ABILITY OFFSET
ANY THESE COST TO PROTECT THOSE
NINE HUNDRED PEOPLE AND GIVE
THEM SOME ASSURANCE BUT
SECONDARILY ISN'T THERE ALSO A.
GRANT PROGRAM THAT WERE
MINISTERING IS PART OF. AND
IT'S GONNA SKATE ME THE BILL
NUMBER IT WAS IT WAS WHAT CAME
WITH THE FENCE. IT WAS WE CAME
WITH THE FENCE LINE MONITORING
LEGISLATION WE DID WHERE WE'VE
BEEN GIVING OUT GRANTS SIX
SEVENTEEN. I WILL BE SO YOU
GUYS APPLIED OR HAS THE AS THE
DISTRICT APPLIED FOR ANY OF
THOSE GRANTS FOR. FOR FANS Là
MONITOR. SO FIRST YOUR FIRST
QUESTION YEAH SO KERN ACTUALLY
WAS THE SECOND REFINERY IN THE
COUNTRY BACK IN TWO THOUSAND
NINE TO GET IT EPA FUEL
REGISTRATION FOR OUR RENEWABLE
DIESEL. THAT'S SOMETHING WE'RE
INCREDIBLY PROUD OF. WE ALSO
GLENN BIODIESEL SINCE TWENTY
TWELVE INVENTING BIODIESEL IN
OUR DIESEL AND WE ALSO HAVE AB
TWENTY A 20% BIODIESEL. PRODUCT
THAT WE INTRODUCED IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WHICH IS NOW ACTUALLY
10% OF OUR DIESEL FAILED. WHEN
IT COMES TO YOU KNOW THE
PROFITABILITY ASSOCIATE WITH
THOSE RENEWABLE FUELS. US
SUFFICE TO SAY HEY THE
RENEWABLE DIESEL WAS INCREDIBLY
DIFFICULT. THE FEEDSTOCK THAT
WE'RE USING IS VERY DIFFICULT
ON THE METALLURGY WE GO THROUGH
KATALYST MUCH QUICKER. IT'S AN
INCREDIBLY CAPITAL INTENSIVE
AND IT WAS A TO A TYPE OF
BUSINESS THAT. WE MIGHT FRANKLY
STILL BE LOSING MONEY ON BUT
CERTAINLY IN THE EARLY YEARS
WELL WE TRY TO WORK THROUGH THE
PROCESS WE WERE OUR OWN PILOT
PROGRAM FOR THAT. BUT THAT WAS
SOMETHING MORE KERN FELT
STRONGLY THAT THE FUTURE IS
RENEWABLES AND SO WE FELT IT
WAS IMPORTANT TO MAKE THOSE
INVESTMENTS NOT TO BE OUT IN
THE MARKET. BUYING COMPLIANCE
INSTRUMENTS INSTEAD REALLY TO
EMBRACE WHERE THE STATE IS
GOING AND TO DO THE RENEWABLE
FUELS. SO THAT THAT WAS
IMPORTANT TO US. AND FRANKLY AS
FAR AS THE PROFITABILITY. IT
DEPENDS ON THE COMPLIANCE AND
THROUGH MY MARKETS AND THOSE
MOVE AROUND A LOT AND WE ALSO
HAVE OVERLAPPING OBLIGATIONS ON
THE FEDERAL SIDE. AND THE STATE
SIDE THURSDAY WE HAVE LOW
CARBON FUEL STANDARD IN CAP AND
TRADE ON THE FEDERAL SIDE WE
HAVE THE RENEWABLE FUEL
STANDARD. UNFORTUNATELY THOSE
PROGRAMS DO NOT LINE UP. SO
FUELS THAT WOULD ACTUALLY HELP
US UNDER THE RENEWABLE FUEL
STANDARD DON'T NECESSARILY HELP
US AND THE CALIFORNIA STANDARD.
WE HAVE TO KIND OF THREAD THE
NEEDLE SO WHAT PERCENTAGE OF
FUEL PRODUCTION IS LOW CARBON.
FUEL RIGHT NOW VERSUS STRAIGHT.
PATROLLING. I THINK IT DEPENDS
ON HOW YOU DEFINE IT BUT OUR-
BEST VIEW OF THE FIRST
COMPLAINT. SO ALL OF OUR FUEL
IS OF THE OFFICE CLIENT BUT
THAT YOU'RE GETTING CREDIT FOR
FROM THE US IF THIS PROGRAM SO
RIGHT NOW WE ACTUALLY HAVE A
RESTRICTION WHEN IT COMES TO
LABELING. AND SO FOR OUR FINISH
DIESEL THAT GOES OUT THE GATE
UP 25% CONTAINS RENEWABLE
DIESEL THAT WE PRODUCE ON SITE
LIKE I SAID WE'RE THE ONLY ONES
IN CALIFORNIA THAT ARE PRETTY
THING THAT. AND UP 25% OF THE
DIESEL ALSO INCLUDES BIODIESEL
SOMETIMES THE KNOWLEDGE AS A
LITTLE BIT TO HIDING VEGETABLES
AND FOOD WERE YOUR CHILDREN
DON'T KNOW THE VEGETABLES ARE
IN THERE. IT'S VERY SIMILAR
WITH THE FEELS RIGHT THE FEELS
ARE IN THERE BUT IT GOES OUT
THE GATE AS DIESEL AND IT'S
ALSO SOLD AS DIESEL. TO GO
ABOVE THE 5% YOU WOULD HAVE TO
ACTUALLY HAVE A SEPARATE LABEL
FOR THE PUMPS WHICH MAKES IT
DIFFICULT FROM A MARKET
ACCEPTANCE. THE WAY WE HAVE
GOTTEN AROUND BAD OR HER DOING
THAT IS THE B. TWENTY PRODUCT
WHERE WE ACTUALLY NOW SELL A
SEPARATE PRODUCT THE HAS THE
TWENTY PERCENT. BIODIESEL SO
THOSE ARE THE AREAS WHERE WE
HAVE THE RENEWABLE FUELS WE
ALSO BRING ENOUGH AND ALL IN
ONE UP 210% ETHANOL. PERCENTAGE
ARE YOU DOING AT THE TWENTY.
I'M 10% OF OUR GASOLINE SALES
WITH ELDER THREE NINE THOUSAND
AND TEN THOUSAND BARRELS A DAY
AND SO. 10% AFTERNOON IF YOU
TOOK MORE OF THAT FORCED BY A
MESS THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
OR OTHER SORTS OF FEEDSTOCKS
AND BEFORE ADD BY MASS OUT OF
THE VALLEY RIGHT. LOCALLY AND
THEN START TO CONVERT THAT INTO
RENAULT WILL DIESEL AND-
GENERATED MORE REVENUE SAY YOU
DOUBLE THE AMOUNT. YOU WHEN
YOU'RE FAR OFFSET WHATEVER THE
MILLION DOLLARS IS OUR MILLION
FIVE THAT YOU NEED FOR THIS
FENCE LINE MONITORING. SO I'M
NOT SURE I ENTIRELY UNDERSTAND
THE QUESTION. I THINK WHEN IT
COMES TO OUR RENEWABLE FUELS.
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT CAPITAL
INTENSIVE AND IT'S HARD ON OUR
BUSINESS THAT WE'VE INVESTED IN
IT BECAUSE I THINK IT'S THE
RIGHT THING TO DO. WE ARE MONEY
WOULD YOU MAKE IF YOU IF YOU
DOUBLE YOUR- PRODUCTION I THINK
THE ISSUE THAT WE HAVE RIGHT
NOW IS WE'RE LOOKING TO INVEST
IN ADDITIONAL RENEWABLE FUEL
OPPORTUNITIES. BUT WE DON'T
HAVE THE CAPITAL AND SO FOR US
TO SPEND YOU KNOW A MILLION AND
A HALF TO THREE MILLION DOLLARS
ON OFFENSE BY MONITORING WHERE
WE ALREADY HAVE THE MONITORING
REQUIREMENTS IN PLACE. RIGHT I
GET THAT I GET YOUR MAIN
ARGUMENT I'M SORRY TO INTERRUPT
YOU I GET THAT I'M JUST TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT HOW MUCH MORE
YOU'D MAKE IF YOU DOUBLE YOUR-
BIODIESEL. PRODUCTION TO BE
HONEST I THINK WE WOULD LOSE
MONEY FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS
BEFORE WE WOULD ACTUALLY CATCH
UP TO THE INVESTMENT THAT WE
WOULD HAVE TO MAKE. AND THEN
HAVE YOU APPLIED FOR THOSE SIX
SEVENTEEN GRANT. WE HAVE NOT
WHY. I DID NOT EVEN KNOW THEY
EXISTED UNTIL WE TALKED ABOUT
THEM IN THIS COMMITTEE BUT IT'S
SOMETHING I'LL BE LOOKING INTO.
SEEMS LIKE A GOOD OPTION. AND
ACTUALLY ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WE'VE BEEN DOING IS WE'VE BEEN
AGGRESSIVELY MEETING WITH THE
REGULATORY AGENCIES AND TALKING
ABOUT OUR DESIRE TO EXPAND OUR
RENEWABLE FUELS. AND LOOKING
FOR OPPORTUNITIES WITH AIR
RESOURCE BOARD AND ALSO WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION. OF WHERE WE CAN GET
HELP. YOU KNOW NOT TO CLIMB
BACK UP ON MY SOAPBOX SO TO
SPEAK BUT- 80% OF SMALL
REFINERS IN THE COUNTRY HAVE
GONE OUT OF BUSINESS IN THE
LAST TWENTY YEARS. IT IS AN
INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT MARKET. WE
ARE DOING THE BEST THAT WE CAN
TO BE A GOOD CORPORATE CITIZEN
AND TO EMBRACE THE STATE'S
CLIMATE. AND RENEWABLE FUEL
GOALS BUT IF WE'RE REGULATED AT
THE SAME CAPACITY AS A
MULTINATIONAL YOU KNOW BILLION
DOLLAR PLUS MARKET CAP
CORPORATION WITH FACILITIES TEN
TIMES OUR SIZE. WE CANNOT
SURVIVE. AND SO THIS REALLY IS
ABOUT DOING WHAT MAKES SENSE
FOR OUR FACILITY AND MAKING
SURE OUR DOLLARS ARE BEING
SPENT IMPROVING THE COMMUNITY.
GET IT I JUST YOU HAVE A I'VE
MET WITH YOUR. LOBBYIST THEIR
SOPHISTICATED PLAYERS GIVE SOME
VERY. CAPABLE ADVOCATES HERE
FOR YOU IN THE SENATE AND THE
ASSEMBLY. HUNDREDS OF OTHER
PEOPLE OF FIVE OR SIX SEVENTEEN
GRANTS ACROSS THE STATE. I JUST
I DON'T I DON'T SEE WHY THAT
AND YOU TALK TO THE
ADMINISTRATION ALREADY AND
NOBODY BROUGHT THIS UP AS A
POTENTIAL OPTION SO I THINK
WHEN IT COMES TO SIX SEVENTEEN
GRANTS OBVIOUSLY SIX SEVENTEEN
IS AN ENTIRELY DIFFERENT
PROCESS. AND WHAT WE'RE
PURSUING RIGHT NOW WOULD NOT
AFFECT SIX SEVENTEEN AND SO THE
REQUIREMENTS THAT COME DOWN.
UNDER SIX SEVENTEEN IS
SOMETHING THAT WE WOULD LOOK AT
SEPARATELY RIGHT NOW WE DON'T
KNOW WHAT THOSE REQUIREMENTS
ARE THEY'RE STILL DOING THE
COMMUNITY PROCESS BUT I DO I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE COMMENT
OF THE GRANT MONEY AND IT'S
SOMETHING LOOK INTO. AND I WILL
SAY WHAT IT COMES TO FOR
SOPHISTICATION THIS IS MY FIRST
TIME TESTIFYING BEFORE
COMMITTEE LIKE THAT'S GREAT
WELL I AS MUCH AS I APPRECIATE
OUR OUR HELPERS EARNESTNESS IS
REAL AND I TOTALLY GET THAT
WERE JUST TRYING TO FIND A
CREATIVE WAY AROUND THIS AND-
TO AVOID THE PRECEDENT SETTING
NATURE AND STILL. TO LET YOU
GUYS KEEP KEEP YOU KNOW STAY IN
BUSINESS BUT DOING AWAY SAID.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO. CREATE. ADD
PRESIDENT IN THE STATE AND IT
SOUNDS LIKE IS IT BEING
LITIGATED THIS THE SOUTH COAST
DECISION DO WE KNOW IS THAT
ACTUALLY IN COURT RIGHT NOW AS
FAR AS I KNOW IT'S NOT BEING
LITIGATED RIGHT NOW AND I THINK
WHEN IT COMES TO PRESIDENT WE
TALKED A LOT ABOUT SOUTH COAST
BECAUSE IT'S SO GERMANE. BUT WE
ACTUALLY THERE ARE AS PRESIDENT
OF THE FEDERAL AND STATE LEVEL
FOR SMALL REFINERS BEING
TREATED DIFFERENTLY BECAUSE OF
THE NATURE OF THEIR BUSINESS.
ACTUALLY BEFORE THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD. WE GET THE
BENEFIT OF THE LOW COMPLEXITY
LOW ENERGY USEFOR FIGHTER
CREDIT. AND SO THEY RECOGNIZE
THAT THE FUEL WE PRODUCE HAS A
LOWER CARBON INTENSITY THAN THE
FUEL PRODUCED BY THE LARGER
REFINERS. BECAUSE OF THE NATURE
OF OUR FACILITY. AND SO THAT'S
SOMETHING RIGHT NOW
UNFORTUNATELY KERN IS THE ONLY
REFINERY IN THE STATE THAT GETS
THE BENEFIT OF THAT CREDIT.
BECAUSE WERE THE LAST MILE
REFINERY LEFT THAT'S PRODUCING
TRANSPORTATION FUEL. IF I COULD
JUST RESPOND JUST A SECOND THE
ULTRA LOW CARBON FUEL STANDARDS
THAT ARE GONNA TAKE PLACE ON
THE SOUL FOR TWENTY TWENTY.
KERN IS AHEAD OF THE GAME ON
THIS AND TO LIMIT THEIR ABILITY
TO CONTINUE TO DEVELOP THIS
TECHNOLOGY IS. IS SOMETHING
THAT I WOULD REALLY ASK YOU
GUYS TO CONSIDER NOT DOING. AND
IF I COULD SURPRISE THE BRITISH
GET ALL THE DISCUSSIONS THAT
WE'VE HAD IN DISCUSSING WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION AND EVEN THE
AUTHOR YOU KNOW THEY WERE AN
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE AMOUNT OF PERILS
THERE'S PRESIDENT AND STATE LAW
ABOUT HOW WE DEAL WITH SMALL
REFINERS COMPARED TO THE LARGE
REFINERIES. SO IS SOMETHING
THAT WE'RE LOOKING AND I THINK
THAT'S WHY YOU SAW SOUTH COAST
TO THE ROLE THAT THEY DID THIS
BECAUSE THEY WERE NEVER THE
INTENDED TARGET. OF THE
ORIGINAL LEGISLATION. SKINNER
SO THIS MAY HAVE ALREADY BEEN
FULLY EXHAUSTED BUT- GIVEN AT
SOUTH COAST DID SUCH A RULE
THIS DOES NOT NEED A LOT THIS
IS NOT NEED A STATUTE WHY
DIDN'T AIR DISTRICT. IN YOUR
AREA. ACT SIMILARLY AS SOUTH
COAST DID. I'M YOU KNOW I DON'T
THINK THAT THEY HAVE ALL SAY
THESE ARE MY WORDS AND NO ONE
ELSE'S MAYBE THE CLOUD AND THE
MIGHT OF THE SOUTH COAST.
OBVIOUSLY SOUTH COAST TENDS TO
BE A LEADER AND ON THE CUTTING
EDGE OF KIND OF THE REGULATIONS
AND REALLY THOUGHT FOR STANDARD
IN THE STATE. I THINK OUR LOCAL
DISTRICT REALLY WANTS TO BE
REASONABLE BUT THE POSITION AS
I UNDERSTAND IT IS THEY DON'T
THINK THAT THE CURRENT
REGULATION IS CLEAR. THAT THERE
IS YOU KNOW A 100% THAT A
THIRTY FOR THEM TO TAKE THAT
POSITION AND FOR THE DIRECTION
THAT WE GOT YES. STUDENTS OUT
BECAUSE IT'S NOT BEING
LITIGATED I WAS GONNA SAY IF
YOU WANT ME TO TESTIFY AND ALL
THE TIMES THAT REGULAR YEAH
YEAH YEAH YOU DON'T AGREE WE'RE
GONNA HAVE VERY LONG. YEAH YEAH
YEAH. THAT'S TRUE. YEAH AND SO
WE'RE WE'RE JUST TRYING TO DO
IT THE RIGHT WAY WERE TRYING TO.
WE'RE TRYING TO MAKE OUR CASE
AND BE TREATED THE WAY WE
SHOULD HAVE BEEN TREATED
FRANKLY FROM THE BEGINNING AND
UNFORTUNATELY WE'RE NOT. FUND
STAFF REPORT ON PAGE TWO TALKS
ABOUT GIVING THE AUTHORITY TO
THE DISTRICT AND HAVING THEM
GIVING. GIVING CURRENT OIL OR
FROM EVER MAY BE THE- THAT THAT
PROVIDER THAT GUIDES I MEAN IF
THE MAYOR CG BILL SPELLS OUT.
THAT THIS WAS TO APPLY TO
EVERYBODY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WAS IN THE TORRANCE.
DEAL IN IN A CAVE THE
APPROPRIATE DISTRICTS. THE
AUTHORITY TO GIVE GUIDANCE TO
FOLKS. IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING
THAT YOU SHOULD RECEIVE NO
GUIDANCE FROM SAN JOAQUIN.
VALLEY NOT NOTHING ON THIS ON
THIS ISSUE. THEIR SILENCE SO
THEY ARE PRESUMED THAT YOU MUST
HAVE. ONE MONITORING ON THE
FENCE LINE AND EVERYTHING ELSE
RIGHT I YOU KNOW I THINK THAT
THEIR RULE AND WHAT THEY'RE
GOING TO REQUIRE FRANKLY IS
STILL IN DEVELOPMENT AND SO I
THINK THE POSSIBILITY OF THEM
HAVING A RULE IN PLACE AND
GOING TO THE PUBLIC PROCESS.
BEFORE THE END OF THE YEAR IS
UNLIKELY AT THIS POINT AND NOT
BUT THAT'S OBVIOUSLY IN A
DIFFICULT POSITION LIKE I SAID
I AM VERY APPRECIATIVE OF THE
WORK THAT THEY'RE DOING I THINK
THEY'RE TRYING TO STRIKE THE
RIGHT BALANCE. BUT THIS DOES
SEEM SOMETHING APPROPRIATE
GIVEN THAT IT CAME FROM THE
LEGISLATURE FOR THE LEGISLATURE
TO PROVIDE THE CLARIFICATION OF
WHAT THIS BILL REALLY WAS
INTENDED TO ADDRESS. AND TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE NOT. WE'RE
NOT PUTTING THE PRESSURE ON THE
LOCAL DISTRICT BUT TYPICALLY IN
THIS SITUATION. TYPICALLY IN
THIS SITUATION IF THE LOCAL.
APPROPRIATE AGENCY HAS NOT
DEVELOPED RULES THAT THEY NEED
TO DO BY JANUARY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY WE ASK FOR ANOTHER YEAR
WE ASK FOR ANOTHER YEAR. TO
GIVE THEM THE TIME TO MAKE
THOSE LOCAL DECISIONS. THE
PROPOSAL BEFORE US IS NOT FOR
NOT TO MATCH SOUTH COAST. IS TO
GO 255% SO WHAT'S THE
COMPELLING REASON OR FIFTY
FIVE. THOUSAND BARRELS. OR
GALLONS VERSUS FORTY SO WHAT
WOULD BE. IN MY MIND IT'S HARD
TO SWALLOW YES IF YOU ASK FOR
MORE TIME FOR SAN JOAQUIN.
VALLEY AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
DISTRICT ISSUE TO COME UP WITH
APPROPRIATE. GUIDANCE FOR SMALL
REFINERS AND WILL DEAL WITH
THAT AS THEY GO THROUGH THAT
RULE MAKING THAT'S ONE THING
BUT THIS IS ASKING FOR A- NO
LOOK AT FIFTY FIVE THOUSAND.
GALLONS. GALLONS BERYL'S ERROL
SORRY I GET THE RIGHT PERSIST
FORTY WHICH IS WE'VE HEARD FROM
SOME OF THE ADVOCATES THEY
BELIEVE IS UNWARRANTED SO I
THINK AN IMPORTANT DISTINCTION
TO MAKE IS THIS IS ACTUALLY A
MUCH MORE RESTRICTIVE.
EXEMPTION THAT THAN THAT WHAT
IS CURRENTLY PROVIDED BY SOUTH
COAST BECAUSE IT'S A TWO FOLD
TACT THE FIFTY FIVE IS BASED ON
EXISTING STATE LAWS THAT
RECOGNIZE THE SMALL REFINERIES
AND SO THAT IS WHY WE USE THAT
CRITERIA. THAT'S WHY THAT
CRITERIA WAS USED THE SECOND
PIECE OF CRITERIA HAS TO DO
WITH POPULATION DENSITY AND IS
EXTREMELY RESTRICTIVE ADDS TO
THE POPULATION DENSITY AROUND
THE FACILITY WHICH IS DESIGNED
TO NARROW. THE SCOPE OF THE
EXEMPTION EVEN MORE BECAUSE THE
ORIGINAL PURPOSE OF THE BILL
WAS REALLY FOCUSED ON
REFINERIES THAT ARE LOCATED IN
CITIES AND DENSELY POPULATED
URGENT URBAN CENTERS. TO BE
CLEAR. I AM VERY CONCERNED AND
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
PROTECTING ALL OF THE PEOPLE
AROUND OUR REFINERY AND I'M NOT
SAYING THAT TO SAY THAT THE
RULE. NATURE OF IT MEANS THAT
WE DON'T NEED TO PAY ATTENTION
TO IT I THINK THAT THE TWO
CRITERIA LIMITS THE
APPLICABILITY. AND IT LOOKS
REALLY AT THE SMALL REFINERIES
THAT SHOULDN'T HAVE TO BE
IMPLEMENTING THESE REGULATIONS
AND LIKE I SAID A MONITORING
SYSTEM IS NOT GOING TO PROVIDE
A BENEFIT TO THE VALLEY IS NOT
GOING TO PROVIDE A BENEFIT AND
ACTUALLY REDUCING THE EMISSION.
BUT IF WE'RE ABLE TO SPEND THAT
ONE POINT FIVE TO THREE MILLION
DOLLARS. TO DO ACTUAL EMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS PROJECTS THAT'S
WHERE WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE THAT POSITIVE EFFECT. AND
SO THAT'S REALLY OUR CONTENTION
IS THAT THIS. THIS IS WAS NOT
INTENDED FOR A FACILITY OF OUR
SIZE AND OUR MAKE UP IT'S NOT
GOING TO PROVIDE A REAL BENEFIT
TO THE COMMUNITY AND WE CAN DO
OTHER THINGS WITH THOSE FUNDS.
TO REALLY HAVE A DIFFERENCE IN
THE VALLEY THE END SENATOR I
THINK THAT'S WHY THEY WANT TO
JUST COME BACK TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND ACTUALLY LOOK
FOR LEGISLATIVE FIX BECAUSE IT
WAS NEVER INTENDED CON. AND THE
INTENDED CONSEQUENCE TO GO
AFTER A SMALL REFINERY. LIKE
SHE SPEAKING ABOUT SO THEY SAID
WELL IF WE GO BACK TO
LEGISLATURE AND FIX THAT. YOU
KNOW THAT BE THE PREFERRED
ROUTE RATHER THAT NOW DEALING
WITH OKAY SOUTH COAST IN A ROLE
SAN JOAQUIN STILL CONSIDERING
THE ROLE AND MAYBE THEY'LL BE
LITIGATION MAYBE THEY'RE NOT
BUT IF THEY WERE NEVER INTENDED
CONSEQUENCE. WHICH YOU CAN
VERIFY WITH THE AUTHOR OF THE
BILL IN THE ADMINISTRATION AS
WELL. THEN THEY WERE THINKING
WELL MAYBE WE CAN HAVE A
LEGISLATIVE FIX AND JUST BE
DONE WITH THE ISSUE. YEAH BUT
THAT MEASURE THE CHAIR I'M
SORRY THROUGH CHAIR OF THE
REQUIREMENTS THAT WERE SET
FORTH ARE BASED ON STATE
ASSISTANCE IN LAW RIGHT NOW. SO
THE REASON WE DIDN'T GO JUST
LIKE EQUAL TO OF LIKE AND
JENNIFER WAS SAYING. IS YOU
KNOW FIFTY. FIVE THOUSAND
BARRELS IS WHAT'S- PUT IN
EXISTING STAFF MY- GENERATION.
HAVE KIND OF LIKE A- THIS BILL
DID THIS THE SOUTH COAST
DIRECTION DID THIS AND YOU HAVE
THREE DIFFERENT CRITERIA SO WE
JUST USE A CRITERIA THAT WAS
AND THAT. WAS RIGHT EXCEPT
EXCEPT I WHAT I SEE MISSING
HERE ALTHOUGH IT YOUR TESTIMONY
SAYING IT WHY DON'T SEE. IS THE
DOLLAR FOR DOLLAR. TRANSFER IS
SAYING IF WE IF WE WERE TO PUT
THE FENCE LINE MONITORING IN AT
OUR FACILITY. WOULD COST US A
MILLION DOLLARS. IN WE'RE GOING
TO PUT A MILLION DOLLARS. INTO
REDUCTION OF. CO TWO OR
WHATEVER NEW EQUIPMENT SO THAT
THE YEAR DISTRICT COULD SAY
OKAY WEEK WE CAN GO BY AND WE
JOIN OUR OWN MONITORING. IT
DOES IT'S WE'RE GONNA GIVE YOU
SOME GUIDANCE IF WE BECAUSE WE
WANT TO REWARD GOOD BEHAVIOR
WE'RE GONNA REWORK COULD BE
DIFFERENCE OKAY IF YOU'RE GOING
TO GO IN AND- CLEANUP YOUR
SMALL FACILITIES MEDIUM SIZE
FOR SELL THESE. BIG FACILITIES
WE'LL GIVE YOU A DOLLAR FOR
DOLLAR YOU KNOW TRANSFER
BECAUSE WE KNOW HOW MUCH THE
MONSTERS GO BECAUSE THEY KNOW
MUCH. THE CLEANING THAT'S NOT
HERE BEFORE US THIS IS JUST TO
SAY WERE SMALL WE WANT TO
PROTECT YOU BUT- AGAIN YOU'RE
NOT UNDER OATH AND I I'M NOT
SUGGESTING THAT YOU'RE NOT.
YOU'RE NOT. YOU'RE COMPANIES.
COMPANIES I COULD DO BUT
THERE'S A WHOLE OTHER A LOT OF
LITTLE. REFINING OUR PROCESSORS
IN THIS IN THIS KERN COUNTY AND
ELSEWHERE IN THE STATE. THAT
ARE GOING TO BE BENEFITING FROM
THIS THERE'S TWO. NOW AND WE
ARE ACTUALLY THERE AREN'T OTHER
FACILITIES IT'S VERY LIMITED
NOT FIGHT THE DISTRICT ISSUE
WHERE KERN IS THE ONE THAT
ISN'T A BENEFICIARY OF A
CURRENT EXEMPTION. AND SO THIS
WOULD THIS WOULD HELP US AND
GET US TO HAVE THAT PEOPLE
TREATMENT. AND YOU KNOW AT THE
END OF THE DAY I THINK IF THE
AUTHOR OF THE BILL HAD
INTENDED. FOR REFINERIES LIKE
KERN HAD ATTENDED FOR SMALL
FACILITIES IF THAT'S WHAT. THE
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL SAID CAN
WE WOULD BE HAVING A VERY
DIFFERENT CONVERSATION RIGHT
AND I AGREE WITH YOU SPEND THE
FIX REALLY WOULD BE DOING IT
THROUGH THE LOCAL DISTRICT ARE
TRYING TO GET. MORE TIME OR
SOME CLARITY. BUT BECAUSE THE
DIRECTION THAT WE GOT WAS. WE
WERE NOT THE INTENDED TARGET
THIS DOESN'T MAKE SENSE AT A
FACILITY LIKE UP. THAT'S WHY.
EXEMPTION SEEMS APPROPRIATE
ENOUGH AND STUFF. I FEEL
UNCOMFORTABLE. GIVEN THE DESIRE
TO IMPROVE AIR QUALITY FOR ALL
THE CITIZENS ARE KERN COUNTY
THIS TIME GIVEN I GUESS THE
LACK OF EFFORT BY THE AIR
DISTRICT I GUESS I GUESS IF
IT'S ONE THING FOR LEGISLATORS
AND THE. THE COVERED ENTITIES
BUT THIS IS WHAT THIRD THIS IS
WHAT YOUR JOB IS TO PROVIDE THE
GUIDANCE ITS THAT'S CLEARLY
SAID AND L<c.cyan>G AND LANGUAGE SO</c>
WELL AND I THINK FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY
OUR AIR POLLUTION DISTRICT HAS
A LOT ON HIS PLATE THERE ARE A
LOT OF THINGS THAT IT'S
PURSUING THERE'S A OT OF
THINGS THAT IT'S DOING. AND
FRANKLY WE WOULD RATHER HAVE
THEM SPENDING THEIR TIME ON
OTHER THINGS THAT ARE ACTUALLY
GONNA HAVE A BENEFICIAL IMPACT
ON OUR COMMUNITY AND SO THAT'S
WHERE I'M BECAUSE WE THINK THE
LACK OF CLARITY IS AT THIS
LEVEL THAT THIS IS THE
APPROPRIATE LEVEL TO. TO
CLARIFY INTO THE CHAIR AND SIR
THERE'S ONLY TWO I THOUGHT
THERE ARE THERE'S ONLY ONE KERN
IS THE ONLY ONE I THOUGHT THEY
WERE TOO BUT THERE'S NOT KERN
IS THE ONLY DID THE ONLY ROOF
SMALL REFINER. AND THAT MEETS
THIS CRITERIA AND THAT IS NOT
IN A URBAN FULLY DEVELOPED IN
GOAL CITY AREA. IT'S THE ONLY
ONE. THAT MEETS THIS CRITERIA.
BUT THERE'S SOMETHING THERE IS
THERE'S NO SENSE THERE THERE
ISN'T CITIES YOU'RE SAYING THE
ONLY AND NOT AND THE LANGUAGES
CRAFTED WRESTLING INTO CRAFTED
IS VERY NARROW THIS BILL
AFFECTS CURRENT OIL REFINERY.
THE STATE'S IS THE STAFF IS NOT
BEEN ABLE TO DEFINITIVELY
VERIFY THAT CLAIM. AN ANALYSIS.
I JUST I DON'T LIKE THE WAY
THAT THE WEIGHT YEAH I JUST
LACK OF TIME TO SIR IS WHAT I
WOULD SUGGEST TO YOU. AND AT
THE CENTER. SO I'M- ONE OF THE
THINGS IT'S A. IS THAT A
PROBLEM FOR ME IN THIS
LEGISLATURE IS THE ONE SIZE
FITS ALL. NEVER WORKS FOR MY
LITTLE SMALL BUSINESS EITHER I
GET PENALIZED. EVERYDAY IN MY
NEIGHBORS WHO WERE BUSINESS GET
PENALIZED EVERY DAY BY. HILL
THE ONE SIZE FITS ALL I THINK
THERE. IS SOMETHING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE NEEDS TAKE A LOOK
AT IS THAT THERE ARE
OPPORTUNITIES LIKE THIS WHERE
WE SHOULD BE. TRYING TO. HELP
THERE'S NOTHING IN THIS
LEGISLATION IS GONNA. CHANGE
THE AIR QUALITY THERE I WANT TO
SAY THAT I. THE THAT I THINK
THAT YOU'RE DOING THE RIGHT
THING BY TRYING TO FIND A NICHE
MARKET TRYING TO. BE A LEADER
IN IN. THE ERROR REFINING AND
ADDING BIO FUELS TO IT. SO FOR
THOSE REASONS I REMOVE THIS
BILL. AND HOPEFULLY WE CAN HAVE
THIS DISCUSSION ON THE FLOOR.
NO FURTHER QUESTIONS IN A CLOSE
SOURCE LIKE LAST PRIVATE. OKAY
HAS BEEN MOVED BY WE WERE WE
NEED A SUBSEQUENT FIRST I'VE
SURGERY PLEASE CALL THE- ROLL
FOR THE PERSONAL QUORUM.
SENATOR ALLEN HI HERE HERE
BATES. HERE BATES HERE DAILY
YOUR DAILY HERE HILL HELLO HERE
SKINNER. STERN. STERN STERN
HERE WE CASKEY CASKEY HERE.
OKAY THE DOES SOME OF BY
SENATOR DOLLARS. A SEARCH OF
HIS CAR. ITEM NUMBER ONE AB
TWELVE NINETY NINE THE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. ALLEN
HI ELLEN HI BATES BATES HI
DOLLY DALY AYE HILL. BUILT BY A
SKINNER. SKINNER AYE STERN
STERN NO WAY CASKEY MAKOWSKI NO.
CAN'T FIVE THE TWO. WE GO BACK
TO THE FLOOR THANK YOU EVERYONE